hi everyone it's mike vartos and welcome
to today's
special training on order flow and
today's topic
is everything you wanted to know about
order flows and
you know i've been really meaning to do
this uh presentation for a while
you know because i get a lot of
questions the order flows trader
software really takes order flow
into another level and you know
there's so many different moving parts
in in order flown and i want to show you
you know different ways that you can
approach the market and
you know make i don't say make money but
you know become
a better trader right really that's
that's what it's about you know i i
don't like to talk about
you know in terms of money you know
people ask you know can i make this
amount of money you know per day or per
week
per month but it really it's trading is
an individual thing
right everybody has different risk
tolerance
excuse me levels and you know everyone
else obviously has different amounts of
money that they're going to trade with
so you know that's you know vague
questions like that aren't easily
answered
and what i'm going to show you today is
you know
ways to better your trading you know at
the end of the day
you want to improve right you always
want to be improving whether
you know it's in trading or whether it's
in in your business or you know your
work or your personal life or
your family so
um just a few ground rules i
will be answering questions at the end
and you know
so you know put your question in even if
you can't stay
i have a feeling this presentation is
going to go on
for over an hour at least and you know
what i find that when i ask
answer questions sort of mid-stream they
it really sidetracks my train of thought
sometimes and i just find it's better to
answer at the end so if you have a
question just throw it in there
you know i'll scroll back and and even
if you can't stay on
you know you could watch it on the
replay i'll probably have a separate
replay for just answering questions
so let's uh
let's jump into it gotta make sure my
pointer is on
looks okay you know brief disclaimer
obviously everybody knows
trading involves risk you know
especially the last uh just this year
alone
you know these markets have been pretty
bonkers and
you know i know a lot of people that
also you know
got the trading bug because of you know
what was happening at the end of january
with um you know the short squeeze in
gamestop and everyone all the sun's
talking about silver
back then and obviously bitcoin had been
rallying
you know uh you know basically since
well of last year but you know really
took off in the end of uh
you know around october and you know
going up from about 15 000 up to
obviously where we're at now so there's
a lot of interest in the markets and you
know it's good to have
some sort of education on the market
that can that can you know
put you in good good steed so to speak
when you approach the markets and
let me just move the questions over here
there's volume you know it might be your
computer is
not um got the volume on you know you
could always log out log back in but you
know
it seems like everybody can hear me okay
okay good you got it sorted out
um so today i'm going to take you on a
journey
right you know and it's not like the
lord of the rings type journey
but you know my my goal right what
really what i want to impress upon you
is
show you how easy it is to apply order
flow to your trading
and understand the market better and a
lot of people
honestly get scared with order flow
because they think it's looking at a lot
of numbers
and it is you know you are looking at
numbers but you're not analyzing every
single tick that goes through the market
now
in one of my emails i said i got a
special bonus for you guys
if you know for signing up for this
presentation and
it's there i'll email it also to you
guys um
but what it is in the handouts section
of if you go to your
webinar go to you know you go to webinar
um
what do you call it control panel
there's a section called handouts okay
and i've uploaded them there so you can
download them one is the poc
cheat see cheat sheet which you see here
you know it's just
you know it's just a way to identify
points or controls
that can help you in your trading right
it can be supported resistance or
momentum
and there's also a little pdf on
understanding the order flows ratios
which when i first released the order
flows trader software was
um you know one of the cornerstones of
my analysis and and i still
you know as long as i've been training
overflow i've been using the ratios and
i get a lot of questions
from people because a lot of the other
software's out there sierra charts
um you know et cetera have been adding
these ratios
to their software and you know i'm the
one that
really brought it out to the public i
don't know if there's anybody else also
calculating it might
you know or not but i used to do it by
hand on a calculator or
i could do some of the math in my head
sometimes depending on the numbers
but you know it really the ratios
really help you identify you know price
defense in the market
and price rejection so
most of you know who i am um but you
know
if anybody is not really familiar this
is my picture there
i've worked in the industry
in the futures industry specifically
that's all i did i didn't trade stocks
you know or go into any other
you know forex it's in futures right i
started on the cme floor
commerce bank edf man
jp morgan and obviously cargill
and you know and that's a career
spanning from the early 90s
up until the uh you know the teens right
2013 is when i left jp morgan so
you know it's been a long time and i've
learned a lot
right i've had the very good fortune of
working with
very smart people smart traders and you
know one thing that i found is
everybody's got their own unique style
right you have to develop your own
unique style you can't go out and
literally mimic another trader right
because everybody thinks differently
everybody has sort of you know a
different mindset when they come into
the market some people could handle
you know losing 500 dollars on a trade
other people will start to panic when
they're down fifty dollars so you know
everybody's different
and you know when i left jp morgan i was
trading for myself
but the software that i that was
available at the time i was using
another company's order flow software
right their footprint chart
and you know it was nice okay because
you know it just
it was just at that point it was you
know order flow is
i'll say new i mean you know order flow
had been around you know in that sense
in the footprint chart since i mean
has been around for you know maybe about
10 years more or less
up to that point you know in the past
trading was more visual like you'd see
if you're
on the floor you could see when the big
buyers were coming in and etc
and if you had you know a good floor
broker he would you'd relay that
information to you
but you know when everything started
going electronic really in the early
2000s you know that's sort of when the
footprint chart
really took off and it took order flow
basically to another level but
you know i found that around you know
2013 2014
you know i was sitting there in my forms
of analysis were like well
you know why can't the software
highlight these things to me
and so i sat down with the programmer
who understood the footprint chart
because they already programmed the
footprint chart and you know we got to
work
on releasing what we call the order
flows trader software that was in
2015. now it's 2021 right now we've gone
already this is our third
major upgrade we released back in
october
to the soft to the order flows trader
software and it runs on ninjatrader
eight and people always ask me you know
is it available for tradestation is it
available
for sierra charlie or this other thing
traded you know um
tos you know it's not mine it runs on
ninjatrader eight
because you know when you're looking at
data okay
futures in my opinion is the best market
to trade because the data is centralized
it comes from one source the exchange
the cme group
and you know when you're dealing with
forex you know you got all these
different
front ends basically offered by banks
right so you're basically trading
against the
banks not market makers but you know
their book and all that stuff so
you know you could be trading on one
system and having your
data come from another system and it
could be off a little bit i mean
generally it'll be right but it might
could be off
obviously with stocks you get all these
the dark pools and
you know you got i don't see different
um different data sources there so
that's why i stick to futures but you
know you can use it i do look at some
stocks
as well um you know the main stocks you
know apple
things like that but uh me i just want
to
get enough training opportunities in
futures
and what it is the order for trader
software it's a footprint chart with 17
pre-programmed
order flow analysis tools i'm going to
explain all that today okay
and the reason i talk about this is
because you know the charts that i use
in this presentation are generated using
the software okay so you know if you're
using
another company software you might not
be able to see this unless you know what
to look for
and if you are using someone else's
software you know hopefully by the end
you'll understand what to look for in
the market now
you're gonna learn what is working now
in order flows
right you're gonna see new ways of
viewing the market generated information
and you're gonna see easy to trade
order flow trade setups and again you
know the reason why i talk about my
software for a little bit there is
because you know i want you to
understand
that i use those the
software in this presentation and the
chart the
charts that you're going to see i'm just
going to open up ninjatrader take you
right through i'm going to show you
everything
um on ninjatrader stop i mean it's
obviously the markets are closed today
but you know i'm not
showing you a bunch of slides or
anything i'm just going to have the
actual ninjatrader up there
so what makes the order flows trader
different
is imagine just taking your normal order
flow footprint chart and turning it
loose on the market generated data
imagine what's going to show you right
it's going to show you i'm going to go
through all these right i gave you the
list delta divergence exhaustion print
imbalance reversal zero print volume
profile stacked imbalance multiple
imbalance
inverse imbalance unfinished business
market sweep detector
market weakness detector value area
expanded value area overflow sequencing
the ratios prominent points of control
and slingshot point of control
and actually there was a few others that
i didn't even put on this list but as i
was
making the going through the slides
today i said i got to show you that also
now
again having good software i think is
good you know as a trader right you
don't want to just trade over your phone
and you know use the basic you know
everyone likes to think that they're a
trader because you know they could
access the market over their hand phone
but you know nothing beats the power of
a desktop computer
now you know what makes order flow so
special is it gets you as close to the
market what's happening
you can see what's happening on the bid
and the offer right and that's going to
allow you to gauge the tendency that a
market is going to continue in a
direction
it's going to allow you to see new
trading activity which
is coming into the market and what
direction is coming and
you know lastly have better information
than everybody else out there who are
just looking at
you know the open high low close or the
last traded price
you know that's really what you want to
do and
again there's different ways to do
things
i like the path of least resistance i
like to let the computer show me what's
happening in the market
and you know most people their trading
journey they think it's going to be from
point a to point b
in a straight line but the reality is
it's all mixed up right
a lot of traders you come into the
market that's how i'm going to trade the
market
well i got my plan all right well that
didn't work okay next plan well that
didn't work i
gotta do another plan well once you
understand what's happening in the
market
right you don't have to keep changing
your plan right you don't keep changing
the way you trade the market because
you're going to understand what's
happening in the market
and when you organize the data right
it's going to give you data points
right it's more than just open high low
close there's delta point of control and
imbalances
now i'm not going to really spend much
time talking about this hopefully you
guys haven't already
most people already nowadays have a good
understanding of what delta
is in the order flow it's the difference
between aggressive buying and aggressive
selling
the point of control is the price level
in the bar with the most volume
imbalances is when there's more
aggressive buying or selling
in the two-way auction usually by four
to one now
most people think order flow is about
reading the time and sales
okay well yeah order flow comes from the
time and sales
okay and there's a lot of information in
there
if you know how to analyze it right and
when i started
in my careers right at the time when
globex was starting up
right and and i traded globex from the
mid-90s
okay when there really wasn't much
activity going on so it was easy to
watch time in sales
right they even had this little thing
called the ticker so you could even see
who the aggressor was
on the board of trade the board of trade
had the aggressors cme at that time did
it now the cme owns the border trade
but nevertheless you know that's why you
see
on the time and sales different colors
because
if it's red it means that someone was
the aggressor right someone was selling
into that bid
when it was green someone was the
aggressor the buying aggressor they were
buying the offer
okay now a lot of people nowadays think
that
reading the depth of market the the the
dome
right the price ladder is they think
that's order flow well that's orders
going into the market but not
necessarily getting filled so
you know then you sort of come down into
semantics about it all right so
you know is this order flow or not well
order flow
is about what's actually trading in the
market in my opinion right yeah you can
make that argument that
looking at a dome is um
reading the order flow but really if the
market's trading in this case 3339
right and someone offers something up
here at 33.41
well right now it's got no effect on the
market that's so far off
right but you know if 500 traded at
33.39
that's information i can use okay so
let's just talk a little bit about the
summary content now
this is where i'm going to get into
using the order flow so you know on
ninjatrader
right this is the ninjatrader control
panel okay
it's very very simple to get started
right all you got to do
to add the software is you just click
here import
ninja script add-on okay once it's added
on
you just open up a chart simple right
you just go over here i'm going to show
you how to set up a chart literally from
scratch okay
um i'll just use e-mini's for now
got to have tick replay enabled right so
that way it will load the historical
data
up until right now okay if you don't
have tick data enabled
um your footprint will start when you
load the chart okay so
after you click that what it pulls up is
let me just get this other thing out of
the way this is my testing pc that i'm
running
this webinar on so this is your
simple standard chart right that comes
from ninjatrader right black background
i don't like black
honestly but you know a lot of people do
but
i'll show you once you install
ninjatrader on here all you got to do
add it to your screen okay you just find
it right here it'll appear at the top
okay all right it's not going to appear
under
you know inside under alphabetically
right
our indicators appear at the top because
we put a space in between so don't look
up you know
order flow down in here all right it's
going to be at the top
okay so let's find it here order flow
trader
click on it so it appears down here i
think i click
on it twice now yeah just move one
so you know when you have the software
you know there's a license for it okay
so you just
copy and paste your license token in
here and all this stuff
all these defaults are already set to
what i use
okay which is fine for most people and
it's set to a
one minute e-mini chart so you know
depending on the chart that you're using
you may want to change it
so let's see here so i'll click apply
okay
and you can see it says calculating
right so it's going through
you know it's reading the historical
data and it's plotting it on the chart
the first time you load a chart
you know it could take a little i'll say
a little while but you know
20 30 seconds hopefully depending on
your computer now if you have an older
computer
you know it may take a bit longer you
know i still know people that
are using windows 7. you know i love
windows 7. um
and you know i was i was kicking and
screaming getting to windows
8 or not windows 8 windows 10.
um you know but once i made it once i
made that switch
then you know i was fine you know and i
got used to it you know
change is hard for a lot of people so
don't
uh you know if you're still on an old
system
you know upgrade it you know it's not
going to
um you know hurt you and if you're on an
older computer i mean nowadays computers
are so cheap
you know you could you could literally
buy you know you go to costco
or you know there's a place that i like
to buy computers from
um you know my kids are in all these uh
you know doing home school
learning and there's this website
you know i buy for their stuff
you know this tiger direct i mean they
have new computers they also have used
but you know you can get something
decent right if you're if you're still
on an old laptop that's
you know an i3 with eight gig of ram
you know and you know 128 ssd
you know you they even had deals here
right you could go in and
buy a refurbished computer which got a
warranty on it
you know for for pretty cheap you know
it's 349 you know something like this
16 gig ram 512 gig ssd windows 10.
yeah sure it says refurbished but you
know what it's it's
you know the computers i bought for my
kids you know for their homeschooling
and
they do a lot of other junk on there
that they shouldn't be doing that works
fine for them
okay so here's the chart so it's come up
now
obviously it's on the black screen i
have my chart optimized for
a white screen okay so what you got to
do not in here
you click on the chart go to properties
and
you just scroll down here chart
background change the color from black
to white and text is white right now so
if you have a white background
obviously you can't read it so i change
it to black the axis which is this
lines on the side you know that's white
so
obviously on on a white background it's
not going to show up so i changed that
to black
cross hairs i changed to black right um
crosshairs is so you know if you like to
use the crosshairs on your chart
now another thing i like to add on is
this thing called
date and range so it'll show up here
right it says order flows trader but
also show the date
and the range on your screen for the
chart
one other thing i like to change is this
the font size for the axis here
right the time and the price 11 is kind
of small
i'm getting old so my eyesight isn't
what it used to be so i just change it
like that boom
you're done okay now depending on the
market that you're trading
there's different settings in here
okay and i'm going to get to them in a
moment but if you load your chart up
let's say you load up a nasdaq chart and
you have this market sweep
detector enabled it's going to show a
lot of green lines
okay so um you know you probably
might want to disable that initially
like you can see here there was some
red and green zones drawn out but what
i'll talk about
now is the summary content you know sort
of you know what you want to look for
look at rather as in terms of
you know order flow information okay so
here's my chart right you can see down
here i have delta max delta min delta
cumulative delta
and volume okay now in the chart in
in the settings you can adjust what you
want to look for and the reasons why
there's other information you could look
at okay you can look at the
ask volume the bid volume cumulative
delta cumulative delta divided by volume
which you know before when the markets
years ago 10 years ago and the markets
weren't as crazy as they are now
you know people use that a bit more the
delta max delta min delta total volume
so if you put a check there that's what
it appears so you can see i just had
cumulative delta delta
max min and volume now the ask volume is
just
the total volume traded on the ask right
what people were buying
from the offer the bid volume is what
people were
trading at the bid aggressive sellers
were selling into the bid
cumulative delta is the delta for the
whole day up to that point
up to that bar okay so you can see
right down here cumulative delta you
know is 8
000 growing 9 000 10 000 so it's getting
stronger
the delta max delta min delta i'll talk
about that in a minute total volume
you could put the total volume for the
day but honestly it's not something i
really pay much attention to because
generally the volume's pretty
healthy you know you're trading hundreds
of thousands of contracts you're not
going to say well you know we only
traded
um you know it's it's 10 30 in the
morning we've only traded
870 000 whereas normally we trade 970
000 so volume is like that must mean
something
you know that's really split in the
hairs um in a sense
as long as there's healthy volume as you
can see by just watching the normal
volume per bar
okay so what is this information means
down here
let me put the crosshairs on
right this information so delta right so
if you have delta
of say here's this red bar is minus 110
okay it means that there was more
aggressive selling than aggressive
buying in that bar by
110 that's why it's negative whereas
this bar here this big green bar
up you got positive delta 329 that tells
you there was more aggressive buying
than aggressive selling in the bar okay
by 329 contracts
here was six which was you know
basically
zero i don't say zero it's basically
neutral six right such a small volume
in terms of delta and the total volume
for the bar is six thousand five hundred
seventy eight but he only traded six
contracts so that's
that's very light in terms of
delta either positive or negative now
you have max delta you have min delta
and what these two
numbers represent is how strong
in terms of max delta how strong
positive delta was
in the bar okay and you know there's
relationships
between max delta and final delta max
delta min delta and final delta
and min delta is how negative delta was
in a bar so you can see here minus 207
okay so it's telling you that at the
strongest
selling in that bar it only got to minus
okay so again let's just sort of talk
about these relationships and and how
it's important is
well you can see as this you know this
market was just basically going sideways
he's got a little bit of selling coming
down here but as you're coming down
right this red bar it's got negative
delta
very small max delta 33 very strong min
delta minus 501
okay obviously that's bearish right then
you get here this bar
final delta is 6 positive but you know
that's
that's negligible it's neutral max delta
was 257
min delta was -207 so you know it's
there was some selling but then it came
back with some buying and the bar
basically ended up
you know unchanged in terms of delta
then the next bar big bar
up big green bar up positive delta 329
max delta of 473 so
you know i know i had very decent
positive delta 473
and we close in you know decent positive
delta 329
i look at the selling you know it's only
negative 71.
so it's telling me you know there was
really there was some aggressive selling
but really not much and it probably
happened early in the bar
so you know it's telling me now it's
it's turned positive so you can imagine
you know what's going on this market is
coming down
you can see the delta the max delta the
min delta relationships
um you know min delta's growing minus
267 minus 501 then it sort of comes down
here
and it's mixed right it's -207 positive
207.
then as you start going back up you see
the max delta is strong
as well as the final delta and the min
deltas
are kind of weak it's only 71 only 80
right as the market works its way back
up
so you know there's all sorts of
analysis you can do with that but that's
the
max delta and the min delta you know the
the data that you can
get out of out of that um
those readings okay now the total volume
you know i'll show you the the bar
volume here you know
i'm not really paying much attention to
it you know unless it like really drops
off okay
so you know if it came down in here and
i see the normal volumes are
thousand eight thousand and then we got
two thousand here you know i would look
deeper into this bar and see what's
going on
now cumulative delta right is the delta
the running total for the delta for the
day up to a certain point
and again there's analysis you can do
with this i won't get into that right
now
but obviously if cumulative delta is
growing positive
you know that's that's bullish right
because there's more aggressive mind so
you know yeah
you got more positive delta coming into
the market and you know if cumulative
delta was
say negative um
go negative not really this day let me
you'll hear okay like in the morning
right
it was kind of mixed right this was
friday going into the uh
jobs number okay so you can see you know
cumulative deltas
you know it's small negative minus 300
292 283 205 minus 14.
then you know it turns positive 24
negative again obviously going into the
number it's sort of just flipping back
and forth is quiet
but now you can see it's sort of picking
up it's staying positive staying
positive
all along you know these numbers down
here the second from the bottom
it's all green here right um you know
and it just stays positive
i think then when the number came out it
turned negative right before the number
came out it went back to neutral
back and forth right minus 292 minus 500
then turns positive a few minutes before
um and then you had the obviously the
number came out and we got down here
you know after the the number came out
got down to just positive two
so you know there's there's ways you can
analyze cumulative delta
as well so you know but
that's the information that you could
have on your chart in terms of delta max
delta min delta cumulative delta and
volume
now there's different types of
footprint charts you can have you know
most people are familiar
with the bid-ask footprint chart okay
but there's also delta there's also
volume
and there's also diagonal delta and
let me get my chart back up here so this
is your
your normal bid ask chart right you see
the volume trade on the bid you can see
the volume traded on the ask
you can see the you know the the two-way
auction what traded on the bid versus
the trade on the ask
again you can break it down into
different ways and you know there's
people that trade they don't look at the
bid ask
really what they're concerned is either
the delta
or the diagonal delta okay you know
explain the difference between the two
now the diagonal delta okay i'll just
load that chart up here really quick
and
diagonal delta right remember the the
the market trades
in a two-way auction there's a bid
and there's an offer okay so just really
quick this one's talking about diagonal
delta so
you know if the market is
six bit at seven right and you trade
um one on the bid at six and
ten at seven you know you're going to
have an imbalance diagonally right
in the in the auction you know six
against
seven right and now diagonal delta sorry
just the normal delta
is the horizontal delta at a price
level so at seven what traded on the bid
at seven versus what traded on the offer
at seven so
you know if 100 traded on the bid at 7
versus 10 on the offer at 7. it's going
to show you
a positive i'll show you um it's going
to show you a positive delta
of what is that 90 on the bid
okay but i'm going to show you what the
chart
looks like here and it's taking a while
i just literally loaded up ninjatrader
this morning
so give it a second here there we go
as you can see here right this is
diagonal delta
all right so you can see what was traded
on the two-way auction so you could see
you know
minus 23 here right in the middle right
over here minus 36
right positive 20 minus sorry positive
um 13 8. now
if you were to ask me what do i prefer
to use i prefer to use
just the delta at price and you know
even though you know
i do talk a lot about obviously the
market trade in a two-way auction
um what i've i found for me my own
trading
right the horizontal delta is
more effective now i know people that
that do trade the diagonal delta
right they're always looking for the
imbalances right you know when you're
looking at diagonal delta you're always
looking at the two way auction and when
you're looking at a two-way auction
imbalances are going to play a big role
right because you really want to find
where there's you know where the market
is out of balance basically okay
in that two-way auction now delta
just the horizontal delta let me pull up
a chart you know
is going to be a bit different and
let me see if i can get a something to
write on
up here what is this
uh uh let me get a word document here
just give me a second um just you know
so i could
explain it a little bit easier for you
so
okay here so
on make it bigger here so
you know at uh 38 you know 50 double o
right if there was
60 traded on the bid
and you know 300 traded on or 300 traded
on the offer right it's going to
give you the difference here and give
you the delta number whereas
that's the regular delta footprint on
the diagonal delta
it would obviously be 38 50 and a
quarter
um you know and i'll call it 300 here
and the next one was uh 3850 double o
60 okay so it would measure the delta
between
38 50 30 850 and a quarter on the
diagonal delta footprint
whereas the normal just the delta
footprint is going to give you the
horizontal
at 38.50 you know if it was 60 traded on
the bid
and 30 or you know i should have
different numbers here we'll call it
20. if 20 traded on the bid when it was
38 50 bid
at 50 and a quarter and if it was 38.49
you know all it's looking at 3849.75
it's not going to look at what traded on
the bid here
below it's just going to look at what
was traded
on the offer when it was 38.50 offer so
it's going to see
when was 3850 bid 20 traded there when
it was 38.50 offer
300 traded there okay
and here right it looks slightly
different you know obviously
diagonal delta and regular delta is
going to give you different numbers
but even on these types of charts right
the diagonal delta
and the regular delta
there are ways that you can analyze this
okay now let me
go here during the day session okay
so when you start putting the pieces of
order flow together
right and you understand what's going on
in the markets okay so for example
this bar here okay it's a big green bar
going up right you start going up
and as you're going up right you see the
volume that's up here on the offer
right at 71 and a quarter 71.
71 you know this is 71 and a half
quarter um
73 quarters etc right there's this
volume up here right on the offer
so you have more trading on the offer at
this price this price this price this
price this price
and then the market starts trading down
now all of a sudden people are hitting
the bids
right as the market's going down so you
know you gotta think about
what's happening in the market okay
market popped up here
but it ran into some resistance in here
okay
then as it starts coming off people
start hitting the bids that's why you
see
you know some decent bids getting hit
down here on the way down
so you know there's again there's
there's all sorts of different ways you
could use this analysis right and you
could look at this imagine you just draw
out this
area here right you say well yeah you
know we came up to this area here
right i knew that the first time we came
up here there was some resistance now
what you do
is you throw an offer up here right
anywhere in this
between these two blue lines right mark
it what did it do it came right back up
to this level
where you had that resistance earlier
right
and it reacted to it okay so
you know that's one of the ways you can
use a delta
footprint chart and diagonal delta you
know also has got the same
utility now the other chart is a delt as
a
volume chart okay and
i don't use the volume footprint i use
just normal bid ask
footprint and i use the delta footprint
now the volume footprints is
where's my chart to write on here so you
know
you're going to have your different
prices and it's just going to give you
the volume for that price so it would be
you know whatever 320 here
at 50 and a quarter you know here maybe
um you know 275
at 38 that would be 38.49
spot 75. you know it might be
650 you know etc right 38
49 spot 50 you know then
maybe uh 825 or something you know
whatever
but it's just going to give you the
volume traded
at that price not you know what was
trade on the bid or the offer
or diagonally it's just going to give
you the total volume for that price
and let's see we're not up here again
it's
first time you load a chart sometimes it
takes time for it to calculate
but out of these four
i use bid ask and i use delta the reason
i don't use volume is because
you know i like to see the relationship
between the
volume trade on the bid and the volume
traded on the offer
okay whether it's in the two-way auction
um
or just in in terms of delta okay
and again there are people that
like to use the volume but honestly
they're
the way they use volume is is they just
sort of draw it out in bars
my software doesn't allow that but um
you know it just gives you the number
but anyway
you know that's uh that's besides the
point here so it's come up here so
you just see the volume that's traded
here it's all going to put it on one
side it's not going to put it in the
middle because obviously the candlestick
is in the middle
but it's all just right in here right
and you know you could look at it and
say yeah you know there's decent volume
at a certain level
you know okay but we have the value area
now in a bar which
when i get to the value area you know
and talk about that
it's going to hopefully
you know change the way you you view the
market and
let me just put this back here so you
know that's the the different types of
footprints you can look at you know
you've got four different types of
footprints you could look at
um but really i stick with bid ask and
delta that's what i look at now
let's just talk now in about the other
you know the sort of the different tools
on order flow so
delta divergence now delta divergence
in a lot of software out there is just
when a market makes a new high
and you have negative delta or when a
market has a new low with positive delta
and technically that's your divergence
right because you have a new high but
you have selling coming in or you have a
new low but you have buying coming in so
you know the price and the you know the
indicator in this case delta
are diverging right because you got a
new high but you got
negative activity or you got a new lobe
and you got positive activity
now the order flows trader software i
actually take it a little step further
is you know i like to have price action
involved
right because there's no point in making
a new high
with negative delta and then the market
keeps going higher right
i want to see the market start to
reverse right so i'm going to be looking
for
a new high on a red bar with a negative
delta because you know there are bars
that have negative delta that are still
green
where you have red bars with positive
delta
okay so i like to see the the price
action in the bar
actually confirm it now a lot of people
they don't have that
aspect in you know their divergence tool
but to me that's a very important thing
because why would you get short
on a on a bar that's
trading higher right i mean that's the
worst type of trade you can take
right is you want the market to start
moving down if you're trying to get
short or
the markets start moving up when it's
time to buy
okay and i'll just show you here so
all right on where are we here
delta divergence now all these tools
i'll be talking about it's all
alphabetical
um on the presentation
i sort of jump around a bit but
everything is alphabetical delta
divergence exhaustion prints in balance
so it's going to be red or green okay
now
let me see here
well let me find a different market than
the e-minis
um this is crude oil now there's a tool
on ninjatrader that i like to add into
my charts and it's called
current day open high low close because
you know i like to look at the
relationships between
the opening price
the high the day the low of the day and
what the market's
doing and obviously when you're training
a divergence and
delta divergence it's going to be coming
in at the high of the day
or the low of the day so
this is your delta divergence here okay
let me put the crosshairs on
right you got your new high
you've got negative delta and you got
the red bar
okay so you know that's really what you
want to be
looking for okay you don't want to be
you know there's bars
there's times where it could be it could
still be green and you could have a
small negative delta and it's going to
say we got divergence well
you know that's that's all well and good
but you know you're going to end up
losing
more often than not on those types of
trades and
there's a reason why you can have a
green candle with
negative delta like this part these two
bars here right he's got negative delta
minus 12 minus 69.
well what's happened is you've got some
supportive buying coming in you know
it's it's a form of absorption actually
right because you see the 107 the 127
here you can see the 103 the 107.
so there's people bidding this market
and the aggressive sellers are selling
into it here
selling into it there okay that's what's
causing
the negative delta yet the bar once that
selling pressure
eases up the market returns back to the
level that it was
was going towards and obviously it made
a new high now
so your delta divergence this is the
cell right it's got the red
down arrow um you know this next bar i
had a little move
um about 10 cents let me see if i could
find a delta
divergence a buy signal here let me see
well i need a low i would need a low of
the day
um
nothing there let's
go look at another market real quick
here's treasuries
okay i don't have the current open day
high low close here but this is a
divergence right here
okay let me just throw the current day
high low
and again you know remember years ago
there was somebody selling this
this silly little line here for 250
um as a separate indicator but this is
your delta divergence right
you have your new low new or equal low
this case it's a new low
positive delta and the price action in
the bar is
positive right it's a green candle right
prices are moving higher
that's your divergence right there now
this doesn't mean that every single
divergence delta divergence is automatic
buy or sell
you know i like to use it with ratios
okay that's sort of like my my bread and
butter
you know i know some people they just
like to see the divergence and trade off
of it but i like to use it with the
ratios
um i just find it a bit more
effective for me personally okay
because on a trending market you could
have failed divergence failed divergence
failed divergence
okay now this is you know this is what i
talk about divergence in a ratio here
497.
um it's a blue number and you got your
divergence right
as opposed to just buying any divergence
right if i bought this divergence this
divergence
well they both failed this one you know
could have scalped a few ticks but
here you got your divergence in your
ratio
and you know you had a slightly better
move obviously you're going into the
close here
but you know that's really what i'm
looking for because when you see
divergence divergence divergence that
fails
chances are it's going to keep failing
right because
what's happening in the market is a bit
stronger right there's
what you want to call it um you know
we'll call it
well it's a flow driven market right
because
the the or the flow that's coming into
the market is
really what's driving the market
necessarily not
um technical levels right because you
know on normal
trading days technical levels people
respect them on flow driven markets
they don't get respected so the next
thing i'll talk about
is where are we here delta diversion so
next thing i talking about is exhaustion
prints and it's going to show you when
buying dries up at the bottom of a bar
or selling dries up at the top of a bar
okay
now buying drying up is at the bottom
of an up bar selling that you're drying
up is going to be selling
at the top of a down bar okay so
you know they're unique to each bar
okay so it's not like it's going to be
i'm not looking for selling at the top
of a green bar
i'm looking for buying at the bottom
of a green bar so you can see here three
okay you see a couple here you see this
four
right this little green box seven three
in here i could adjust the the threshold
you can adjust the right in here
exhaustion prints you can adjust the
colors
right i like to use like green and red
um how dark it is you can change the
color you know the opacity i would set
the 50.
but you could change the exhaustion
print size right i use
nine for most markets now there's some
markets i'll talk about in a second
that i use a different level now when i
look at nasdaq or nq i don't use nine
i use a smaller number three okay just
because that market is a lot less
liquid than e-minis now you could also
draw out
sort of a zone right and you can see
here it's set to one which is just
coloring in that one box but you can
draw it out
you know whatever you want you can draw
it out 10
and it's going to show up
so like i was saying right you can
adjust
the quantity the volume quantity and
on markets like treasuries right this is
the 10-year note which trades
very heavy volume you know you can see
the volumes going through at each levels
they're in the thousands right so
you know trying to you find a level
that's got four
you know that that could be important
right
um you know let's take a look here on on
friday actually on treasuries i use a
level of
50 which is you know good solid volume
and you can see here
um right here's a 50
sold off i mean here's a one went up
then you got 29 you got six
you got five right there's as this
market went up it ran into some
exhaustion here right as the market
starts coming down anytime it tries to
go up exhaustion exhaustion
okay obviously the number the non-farm
payroll there at 7 30
you're not going to trade during that
time um if you do you
you get very good intestinal fortitude
but you see here 13 as the market starts
coming out of that number and volume
returns to normal because in here right
you just
you're trading 100 you know 45
small volume but as the market settles
down you know then you revert back to
your analysis right market came down
came back up
as it's going back up it shows some
exhaustion market comes back down
okay you know the way up you got some
exhaustion here
nothing in there yeah you got 21 here
right then you have 41 here at this
swing low right market move back up
swing high up here back up to the open
of the day you got exhaustion
right market came down nothing down
there um
you know in the next bar you got a ratio
you got a
exhaustion showing then you go up you
know come back down a little bit 49 work
your way back
up right now this is you know if you
want to draw these zones out you could
you know i'm just showing you again i'm
not
this was a user request because i have a
user that uses
the software that he trades
you know for the market to sort of test
these levels
um and he wanted this feature in there
so you know
we put it in there but i i don't use
that
myself but it's there if you want to
draw out zones you know because after a
while you know if you start having a lot
of zones on your chart it does get a
little
confusing and even though i show you a
lot of different ways to
analyze the order flow i don't expect
you to use every single one
right you got to use what resonates with
you
and your trading so the next thing i'll
talk about is
imbalance reversals and it's right here
on the chart or sorry on the software
right it's the third
setting in here if you don't want to use
it you just disable it here
and there's it's going to show an arrow
it's going to be red or light green and
again you can change these colors
whatever you like say i don't like to
use
light green i want to use chartreuse you
can change it to whatever you know
you can change it too you know there's
all these different colors you can
change it to
um you know but
i i generally like to keep buys either
blue or green and cells
some shade are red but sometimes i
should i venture into pink
purples so it's gonna be red and
light green okay so i click apply
and again it'll show up
on the charts here's a light green this
is an imbalance reversal
you got this imbalance in here right as
the market's going up
it's an imbalanced reversal bearish one
right in here
now imbalanced reversals are going to
appear when there's imbalances at
certain points in the bar
and again it's going to print a red
down arrow for bearish it's going to
print a green
up arrow for bullish okay
now obviously these are different colors
so these are something else which we'll
talk about
um a bit later
obviously these are something else in
here
you know here's a red one um there's no
no other greens here
let's go back to i'll take a look at at
crude
light green and you know here's a light
green light
green now again these are not designed
to be
you know just oh there's a light green i
got to buy or i got to sell you know
take it in context with what the markets
have what's happening in the market
right you don't just buy and sell every
time you get a an arrow
right it's it's a tool to help you
analyze rather than sitting here trying
to
look at the chart and figure out what
something
means in the order flow okay you still
have to
analyze the market right you still have
to trade
go back here to you know here's your red
right
as the market you know sold off a bit
here's a green just
sort of went sideways this red didn't
work
but when i tried order flow right i like
to have follow through so if i get a
bearish signal
the next bar has to start moving in that
direction
if the next bar just goes back up
doesn't even take out the low of the
signal bar
right like here or like here to me
that's no trade it's not a trading
opportunity
right you want the market to move in
your direction
of the trade right like this one yeah i
would have taken this one but then
what happens i get in and the market
just goes sideways on me right as a
trader you gotta
realize the market's going sideways on
you and get out you know here's
an imbalance reversal you got your leg
green right
you finally took out the high okay you
get long markets moving in my direction
and obviously continued higher
but imbalanced reversals really show um
trapped traders right or potentially
trapped traders
okay now the next thing i'll talk about
is zero prints you know when we released
the earlier version zero prints and
imbalance reversals
were grouped together we broke them out
in the new version
and in the zero prints
in the indicator again everything inside
the indicator is
alphabetized so zero prints is way down
at the bottom down here zero prints so
it's a dark red
dark green as opposed to red and light
green
okay and if you don't want to use zero
prints you just click this button to
disable it
but i have it enabled because i want to
see it so
i'm looking for you know a dark red or
dark green
here's zero prints here zero prints we
got no follow through in the next bar
really what i'm looking for is the
follow through
in the next bar so for example here
right you got the zero prints in here
you can see the zeros
zero zero right you see the four up here
and then zero zero
this next bar it went one tick lower
okay obviously we opened up here traded
higher
went one tick lower i have like what i
call a two and two tick
the market has to move two ticks over
the next two bars finally it breaks here
right and then it goes down i'm not just
immediately getting short
just because i got a zero print up here
i gotta let i let the market
take me in okay here's another zero
print market's starting to move down
okay you can start getting that move
down again it doesn't look like much but
this is a move from
you know four and three quarters down to
one and a quarter
then it just sort of goes sideways so
you had some opportunity for something
there
obviously here's the imbalance reversal
since the markets makes that big
run big tear back up here this zero
print here again
very similar to this zero print here
where you got that push down and then
you just go sideways
you know on other markets
you know if you're looking at it during
the night session you're going to get a
lot of zero prints because
certain markets trade not a lot of
volume so
it's probably not going to be very
effective if you're looking at it at
midnight or you know 11 p.m or something
right you really want it when you know
the volume is active
so like here's zero print but the market
doesn't go anywhere it just sort of sits
there
right doesn't even take out the high of
this bar now again
would i be looking to get long at the
high of the day probably not i'd prefer
to get long somewhere near the low of
the day
that's why i use you know that's why i
always keep an eye on where the higher
the low of the day is
you know here's a zero print this one
the next bar started moving in that
direction right you always want to have
price action on your side right
there's a zero print here a little pop
up here you know
struggled went sideways there's another
zero print
you got that little pop-up pulled back
now where do i put my stop is i my
signal bar the low the signal bar is my
first place i'm going to be looking
as my stop right initially
so it pulls back doesn't even doesn't
stop you out then it makes that
a little bit of a move higher but still
um
you know on different markets you're
gonna be looking at you know different
things
so volume profile most people we know so
zero print happened because fast trading
is occurring at the edges of the bar in
case you're wondering why we have zero
prints now zero prints i use
use a lot in certain markets okay
because
again if you're looking at zero prints
in nasdaq forget about it because
there's a lot of zero prints
if you're looking at you know mini dow
even you can almost forget about it
i wouldn't use it on those type of
charts but you know on thicker markets
they just show you i don't think there
was okay
um let me close this chart um
on the 10-year right well 10-year you're
not going to get many zero prints
i don't think i mean obviously around
the number you will get them
but uh i don't think there are any
well obviously during the number you're
seeing the zeros because it's
going bonkers you know but here there
was a zero print at 8 24.
right and look at that it's a nice move
from you know o2
down into you know below the number now
people say well that's just a small move
well
you got to realize this is the
treasury's right and it's trading
close to close to 100 000 contracts just
to move
you know here and you know the beauty of
a contract like the
10 years is you can move size in there
it's very liquid
and you know you can move 100 contracts
in there you're not going to move the
market
so when you see a zero in there pay
attention to it right
it's very um honestly very important but
you know it's telling you this there's
something going on in that market
right that you want to be aware of
okay so next thing i'll talk about is
volume profile okay
everyone is familiar with volume profile
in um
you know some extent and
you just pull up the chart and the
indicator here
you get added here right now you got
your choice volume
profile you can display it on the right
which is over here you can display it on
the left
so depending on which side of your chart
that you want it on
you can choose to display the the um
you call it the price levels
and you can choose whether to display it
or not
i don't use it so much anymore now that
we have
the volume the value area on a chart
and you know this is where it's going to
be here so you can see those areas
obviously you could stick out
you know and it depends on your trading
style right if you
you know me nowadays i'm a very
short-term trader
in the sense i'm using sub 1-minute
charts 30-second charts
and you know so me you know training
around these volume levels
is not as important as if i was saying
train on a five-minute chart or
something like that or on a range based
chart
you know i want to know where it is and
you know but you know you can see as the
day is happening it's developing it's
constantly developing
um so you can you see you know if the
market comes back up into a value area
or
you know the point of control for the
day you know what does the market do
when it gets back up there you know does
it come back up there and sell off
et cetera so you know you're gonna be
looking for
areas um you know of
you know little areas like this where
the market can get through
you know those low value low volume
nodes right as the market can just blow
right through now again you can put this
on the left hand side or you could put
it on
the right hand side okay
right now it's showing up on the left
hand side but again it's
it's up to you if you want to use it or
not um you know especially on days that
have gigantic ranges like in the s
ps and nasdaq you know it's funny
because even though you know we're
talking about
you know just two percent move in the s
ps is like
80 points now so it's your chart is
really going to be running pretty big
okay so